immaginate di trovarvi su una nave che
sta affondando siete in mare aperto
Circondati dall'acqua gelida senza
alcuna speranza di sopravvivenza
ma improvvisamente vedete una scialuppa
di salvataggio e lontananza
La Scialuppa può salvare solo una
persona e tra voi e gli altri passeggeri
c'è un unico posto disponibile cosa
fareste salvereste voi stessi o del
resto la vostra opportunità qualcun
altro
l'essere umano fin dalla preistoria ha
sempre vissuto in comunità la
sopravvivenza Dipendeva dalla
collaborazione dalla condivisione delle
risorse la nostra storia evolutiva ci ha
permesso di sviluppare società sempre
più complesse e avanzate
studi scientifici dimostrano che
l'altruismo è presente in tutte le
culture e che siamo predisposti a
cooperare con gli altri
l'altruismo è quindi parte del nostro
DNA
Tuttavia la società moderna ci spinge
sempre di più verso l'individuismo la
competizione la ricerca del successo
personale e la cultura del consumismo ci
fanno dimenticare l'importanza
dell'altruismo e della condivisione
spesso ci sentiamo soli isolati e in
gara con gli altri anziché cooperare per
raggiungere obiettivi comuni
individualismo ci fa sentire meno felici
e ci rende anche meno realizzati
l'anno scorso ho svolto un'esperienza di
volontariato a Lourdes come ben saprete
È un luogo di culto e pellegrinaggio ma
non solo è anche un luogo dove molte
persone si recano per cercare aiuto e
conforto
insieme ad altri volontari ho avuto
l'opportunità di poter aiutare persone
malate anziani e disabili e di fare la
differenza nella loro vita
ho incontrato molte persone che stavano
vivendo momenti difficili che avevano
bisogno di un supporto di una mano e di
un sorriso ho compreso L'angoscia la
paura ma ho anche toccato con mano la
forza dell'umanità la bellezza
dell'altruismo la capacità di fare del
bene agli altri
l'esperienza Lourdes ha cambiato
totalmente la mia vita e mi ha fatto
crescere come persona
quando aiutiamo gli altri sentiamo di
far parte di qualcosa di più grande di
noi stessi ci sentiamo utili appagati e
felici
il nostro cervello rilascia endorfine i
cosiddetti ormoni della felicità Inoltre
studi dimostrano che chi si dedica al
volontariato e l'altruismo vive più a
lungo ed è meno soggetto a malattie
mentali come la depressione
Ma perché esistono persone altruiste e
altre No beh è una domanda a cui non
esiste una risposta univoca Certo Ci
sono molte teorie che cercano di
spiegare l'altruismo come ad esempio una
rilettura dell'evoluzione di Darwin chi
suggerisce che gli esseri umani tendono
a essere altruistici perché ciò
favorisce la sopravvivenza della specie
Questo è un bonobo uno scimpanz nano con
il quale condividiamo oltre il 98,5% del
nostro DNA simpatico vero presenta su
scala ridotta un'anatomia molto simile
alla nostra ma con le gambe più lunghe e
il corpo più armonioso rispetto alle
altre scimmie antropomorfe
secondo il biologo belga France de Wall
la nostra specie da una parte ereditato
dai primati aggressività violenza e
forma gerarchica della società ma
dall'altra ha ricevuto altre qualità
come la generosità la gentilezza e
l'altruismo tipiche proprio del bonobo
nel suo lavoro il bonobo e latio The
Wall va oltre e dice che probabilmente
anche il desiderio di equità l'empatia è
la moralità non arrivano con le prime
società umane ma fanno parte della
biologia dei primati
tuttavia credo che l'altruismo non possa
essere spiegato solo attraverso la
biologia o la genetica
l'altruismo è un comportamento che
dipende da molte variabili come
l'educazione L'esperienza di vita la
cultura e il contesto sociale in cui si
vive in una società che ci insegna ad
essere individualisti spesso l'altruismo
sembra essere considerato un optional ci
viene detto di concentrarci sui nostri
obiettivi la nostra carriera ma spesso
ci dimentichiamo che il nostro benessere
personale non può prescindere dal
benessere degli altri
la mia esperienza mi ha fatto capire che
l'altruismo e l'individualismo sono due
forze in contrapposizione che certo
possono coesistere ma solo se ci
impegniamo a trovare un equilibrio
l'altruismo ci spinge a fare del bene
agli altri mentre l'individualismo ci
spinge a perseguire I nostri obiettivi
personali
ma solo attraverso il bilanciamento di
queste due forze che possiamo trovare il
vero successo e la vera felicità
Inoltre l'altruismo non riguarda solo la
beneficenza al volontariato è
un'attitudine che possiamo applicare in
ogni aspetto della nostra vita possiamo
essere altruisti nei nostri rapporti
interpersonali cercando di ascoltare di
aiutare le persone ma possiamo anche
essere altruisti nella nostra vita
professionale cercando di creare un
impatto positivo sulla nostra società
attraverso il nostro lavoro
ora Lasciatemi citare il celebre romanzo
di Il giovane Holden di salenger nel
libro il protagonista dice tutto ciò che
voglio davvero è essere utile agli altri
vorrei essere come un angelo che prende
in braccio le persone e le aiuta ad
andare avanti
Il giovane Holden ci ricorda che
l'altruismo non è un'opzione ma una
necessità
una domanda a questo punto Può sorgere
spontanea Siamo davvero tutti così
indispensabili
moltissimo la nostra presenza è
fondamentale per il mondo in cui viviamo
e il nostro comportamento può fare la
differenza in un mondo in cui le persone
si aiutano a vicenda e uno in cui Ognuno
cerca il proprio interesse personale
E allora quale scelta avesse fatto sulla
nave che stava affondando
avreste lasciato il vostro posto a
qualcun altro oppure l'avreste preso per
voi stessi
la risposta a questa domanda è il nostro
punto di partenza per capire quanto
siamo disposti a sacrificare per gli
altri e a vivere in modo altruistico
Siamo esseri sociali che hanno bisogno
degli altri per vivere per essere felici
non dimentichiamolo
Grazie
[Applauso]